hi i'm denzel washington and i am orson
welles
[Music]
i am jamie foxx and my name is joseph
gordon-levitt
and we are doing today wired
auto complete interview it's even harder
to do this on zoom
that's impossible i'm saying i remember
zoom
come on zoom zoom okay
joseph is joseph gordon levitt a pilot
no he is not i just played a pilot in a
movie
called 7500 and i'm glad that google is
auto completing this that means a lot of
people are watching the movie hey
i'm not a pilot i i mean i i studied to
look like a pilot i think i was
fairly convincing in the movie but uh
pilots go through a lot of training
much more training than what actors do
and uh and it's a good thing
because flying a plane is not easy i
know enough to know how hard it is
if you were my pilot i would feel very
safe
likewise sir likewise so this is the
next question
is joseph gordon levitt nice
[Laughter]
i would say so if you're nice to me oh
i'm nice if you're nice
to me you don't just get
niceness like you get like when you get
hand sanitizer just stick your hand
under you got to actually pump you have
to pump for niceness
exactly if i was just going to just
freely distribute niceness
without knowing that someone was going
to be nice in return i would be all out
of niceness i would be an
empty bottle of hand sanitizer you know
what i'm saying i don't want to be empty
i need to stay full faithful baby thank
you
is joseph gordon levitt left-handed
no my dad was and my grandpa why why is
this
in the autocomplete no this is this is
not a common autocomplete i don't think
i mean why would anybody ask this
i mean is this like some kind of
jerk-off reference because i was in don
john is that what it
is wow you know what
now that you think now that i think of
it yes
i was going to ask that when i met you
it just
slipped my mind hey bro when you get a
private moment
what is jamie foxx birthday
listen my birthday is for everybody to
to share in
i want everyone to share in the birthday
i am 12 13
67 born in the struggle i am a
sagittarius
gemini rising i like long walks on the
beach
what does rising mean i never really
understood this uh i think when you're
smoking weed
got it okay i think i don't all that
other stuff they put on there is just
trying to make you feel like you don't
know your sign like
some girl i was like i'm a sagittarius
yes virginia on your horizon i said
do you want me to know my rise you want
to tell me
i'm african-american rising all right
where does jamie fox live i live in the
heart and the minds and souls of the
people
i am the spirit of living inside of you
that every day that you wake up you feel
me that's where i live so every time
you take that breath you think of jamie
foxx
this is why google can never tell you
the truth
you could google that question all day
long and it would never tell you that
but you just heard the truth what you
just heard
is far truer than anything google would
ever tell you
i'm saying i am in you i got the jamie
and me
i got the jamie and me i got the jamie
hear me
i can't get to that note where did jamie
fox grow
up i grew up 28 miles east of dallas in
a little town called terrell texas
gateway to the east population 12 248
12 247 now because i am here
shout out to terrell man did joseph
gordon levin go to
college i did and then i dropped out
i i dropped out of college because i got
my first copy of final cut pro
which is the first time this is back in
uh 2003
nowadays you can edit a video on your
phone you know there's free video
editing software anywhere you look
but back then in 2003 it was it was a
momentous occasion
that i could edit video
at home on my computer i'd been making
little videos with my parents camcorder
and stuff ever since i was a little kid
and i always dreamed of being able to
edit the videos i would make
and then i got to be an actor and i
would act on sets
and then i would see the things that i
acted in and say like oh
that's the take they chose oh they took
out my paws oh they cut it there
i want to be able to edit and i could
never edit and then finally
finally in in 2003 i got my first copy
of final cut pro
stayed up all night teaching myself
stayed up all night the next night and
the next night
and was just at that point said to
myself i could be
writing these papers for college or i
could be
doing this and it's right around then i
dropped out of college
well all i can say is that we're happy
that you dropped out of college man
because
you've been giving us gems ever since
even before that
did joseph gordon levitt break a world
record is there something i don't know
about i wonder what they're asking about
who is asking this question
i don't know it's just so vague
a world record for what the world record
for
just being the baddest mother on the
planet
i'm just gonna sample that i'm gonna
take that audio and sample it and and
make it my ringtone
make it my voicemail just make but just
play that as often as possible did
joseph gordon levitt learn to wire walk
i did i could walk on a wire back then i
mean it's been a few years since i
practiced but definitely when i was
shooting the walk i could really walk on
a wire i did not walk on a wire that was
110 stories in the air i walked on a
wire that was about 12 feet in the air
which doesn't sound as impressive on
paper but i challenge you to get up 12
feet in the air and get out on a wire
and not be scared your heart gets going
for those of you
hearing the 12 feet just to give you a
reference when you're driving underneath
a bridge it says 12 to 14 feet
he's up high okay i did learn to do it
philippe petit the guy who walked on the
wire between the world trade center for
real the guy who really did it
he taught me he insisted to be the one
to teach me and we spent eight days
straight together and he was like by the
end of these eight days you wouldn't you
would walk on the wall
and uh and i did how did he say i need
that again what do you need jamie i will
give you anything anything you want
who doesn't know this is jamie foxx an
oscar winner oscar winner 2005
ray charles a blessed uh person to do a
blessed movie about him
and pretty good company that year my man
leonardo dicaprio
who's the homie don cheadle i mean
people that i looked up
look up to and admire a fantastic time
and my daughter sat with me
during the oscars she was 11 or 10 or 11
at the time
got to the category she says dad even if
you don't win
you're a great actor and that was all i
needed
that's the sweetest that's so good is
jamie foxx canadian
i am not canadian but i love canadian
bacon i love canada dry
uh i love canadian mist is that
something
i don't know what's that i don't know i
just i thought i thought i had a
canadian mist
is jamie foxx vegan uh actually i'm
baptist
and i've been baptist uh my whole life
like you know to me
jesus is the foundation uh nothing
against other vegans i don't know where
they go as far as heaven and hell is
concerned but i know
where i'm going as far as heaven is
concerned genesis exodus leviticus
numbers deuteronomy
joshua judges ruth for the second
samurai first second kings second
chronicles ezra esther nehemiah job
psalms proverbs ecclesiastic songs album
isaiah
jeremiah invitations ezekiel daniel jose
joel amos over there jonah mike and then
whom zap and i had got
malachi it's about jesus okay nothing
against vegans
but we're going to heaven over here uh
what is joseph gordon-levitt ethnicity
100 ashkenazi jew oh man i thought you
were gonna say uh
african-american anyway what is
joseph gordon-levitt up to i was gone
for a long time i took a couple years
off acting because i'm a dad now and i
spent some time with my kids but i'm
back three movies this year
fantastic man and we love that there was
a point where i was sitting at you
in the scene and i kept staring at you
and you said man it's just
i'm i'm having a good time man and i
really appreciate it because you
you are an important artistic soul ma my
friend here we go what languages does
joseph gordon levitt speak
pretty much english
francaise
is jamie foxx left-handed i'm actually
amphibious in both hands as you can see
i have a pretty big hands so i'm
amphibious
when it comes to that and when i when i
got the rock in my hand
and let all these basketball players
know from lebron to
to paul george to russell uh westbrook
let him all know when i'm when i'm out
there when i go to the left it is what
it is
and you can't do nothing about it is
jamie foxx singing
in rey i did a little bit of singing and
ray at the very beginning
i got a woman read over town
that would do me oh yeah
and then a fun fact right after the
movie came out
i was in the studio with this guy this
kid by the name of kanye west my friend
breon prescott called me and says get
down to the studio
and i did and he was working on this
song called uh gold digger now imagine
hearing the track
and just you know in his raw's form and
then my boy says it ain't right
unless fox gets on it and then we went
into the booth for about an hour and a
half two hours maybe 24 hours i don't
remember
and at one point we went she tagged my
mind
and the rest was music history
is jamie foxx nice they forgot to put
w-i-t-i-t
and my knights with it
[Laughter]
and i'll be damned if i ain't i'm nice
with it wait what what exactly are you
nice with
oh yeah uh well i haven't i didn't i
wasn't necessarily
a specific nicer people i'm a people
person i feel like really
i feel like uh i'm i feel like i'm nice
with the culture
who are joseph gordon-levitt parents
people always ask me why do you have to
have three names well you have to hyphen
three names you have to like have the
longer name is that why
the reason is because my mom's name is
jane gordon my dad's name is dennis
levitt
and uh why should i only take my dad's
name
fair question now i asked my parents
later in life what happens with my kids
are we supposed to hyphenate again like
are they supposed to have four names
are they going to be gordon levitt
hyphen and they didn't have an answer
they said that's for you to figure out i
said thanks that's great
who does joseph gordon levitt look like
people always ask me if i'm the kid in
t2
edward furlong oh i'm not him
but i wish i was i definitely wish that
i was the kid in t2
i order you not to go i order you not to
go
can jamie fox play the piano i've been
playing the piano since i was six years
old i played the piano for my church
uh when i was 13 and my grandmother said
i want you to learn how to play
classical piano so you can go across the
tracks i said grant what do you mean
across the tracks on the white side of
town she says no silly
all over the world music is is respected
and so i
then went on to get a classical piano
scholarship
at international university with where
81 different countries was
was represented just letting you know
i'm well-rounded i believe it
it's not just hip-hop can i take you
home jamie foxx
you know exactly how you can anytime
you're going to take me home you take me
home
and they're referencing to i believe a
song that's on
on an album cannot take you home girl
can jamie fox ride a horse
i can't ride a horse and the horse that
you see in django is actually my horse
her name is cheetah
she now resides on my property i have
actually 40 acres
and two mutants uh cheetahs on my on my
property and legend
is on uh my property and they are
sexy attractive beasts what are the
mules named
uh well the horses cheetah and legend oh
so they're not mules they're horses yeah
yeah i mean you know i had to upgrade
you know i'm gonna be riding around on
the mule that's not sexy
you wanna go ride on some mules um sure
that's odd but okay
thanks water for watching us i hope you
learned a little something about
us my eyes are red because i've been
laughing it's not for any other reason
and thank you for watching hope you
learned something about us